what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if this
is your first time here my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about all things data data science
statistics and programming subscribe for
all kinds of content just like this and
at the notification bell so YouTube
notifies you whenever I upload a video
I'm gonna talk about a concept that all
too often gets forgotten when people
interpret results in the fields of
applied statistics and data science and
that effect is called regression to the
mean
also known as the regression effect this
has some pretty major implications in
those instances when you're doing
subsequent or even repeated measurements
over time and if you're unaware of it
you can come away with some pretty
serious misinterpretations so I'm going
to give you a definition of regression
to the mean then I'm going to explain
why it's true and then we're gonna go
through an overview of some of its
implications here's the definition so
let's suppose somebody takes two
distinct measurements and for sake of an
example let's just say somebody's taking
a test then they take a subsequent
follow-up test but it could be anything
and then we observe that the first
measurement is somewhat extreme either
high or low that individual is likely on
average to be closer to the mean on the
subsequent tests now this is just a
statistical tendency it's not guaranteed
to happen but especially as you start to
take repeated measurements this becomes
more and more likely to occur
now you're hopefully asking yourself why
this is the case so I'm gonna walk
through three different ways in which
regression to the mean can be
demonstrated the first way to
demonstrate regression to the mean is
what I like to call the all chance
versus no chance scenarios and if we
come back to our test score example I
think almost everybody intuitively would
agree that the measured score is equal
to your ability Plus chance now let's
think through two different extreme
scenarios if the measured score came
down 100% to look our chance or error or
whatever you want to call that or if
there's no luck or chance involved
whatsoever let's think about the
z-scores here so if it all came down to
chance
then we would expect the z-score of the
measurement to be equal to zero right I
mean that's the expected value of a
normal 0 1 distribution and we're
assuming here that the chance isn't
biased in one direction or the other
that is lucky versus unlucky being more
likely than the other if none of it had
to do with chance then every measurement
would be exactly the same the
measurement would be exactly equal to
ability and so we would get that same
score each and every single time
turns out reality it's somewhere in the
middle there's always going to be some
ability and some chance that comes into
play
so our z-score is expected to be
somewhere between those two extremes
it's expected to be between a z-score of
0 that is the mean and the z-score from
the previous measurement now on the
threat of z-scores let's put this in
another way and let's just assume we
have a formula Z 2 equals Z 1 plus
chance Z 1 is the z-score of the first
measurement Z 2 is the z-score of the
second measurement it's a statistical
rule that have two variables let's call
them x and y are independent then the
variance of X plus y is equal to the
variance of X plus the variance of Y if
we apply that rule here we would end up
with the variance of Z 2 is equal to the
variance of Z 1 plus the variance due to
chance and we've agreed that the
variance due to chance is greater than
zero so one of two things has to be true
here either the variance of Z 2 is
greater than the variance of Z 1 or our
whole original premise was off turns out
it's the latter it turns out that for
the variance of Z 1 and Z 2 to be equal
and for the variance of sums rule to
hold true here Z 2 has to equal C times
Z 1 plus chance where C is some constant
between 0 & 1 as a result the expected
value of Z 2 equals C times the expected
value of Z 1 as a result the expected
value of the z-score is going to be
closer to 0 meaning the measurement is
expected to be closer to the mean than
the first one now another way to
demonstrate regression to the
it's through the simple linear
regression equation let's consult our
good friend Wikipedia for this one so we
start from the simple linear regression
equation y equals alpha plus beta times
X where alpha is the intercept term and
beta is the slope term and we obviously
have the well-established least squares
estimates alpha hat and beta hat beta
hat is the correlation coefficient times
the standard deviation of Y over the
standard deviation of X alpha hat equals
y bar minus beta hat times X bar where Y
bar and X bar are the sample means of Y
and X respectively
so now just plug alpha hat and beta hat
into the equation for y to arrive at the
fitted value y hat and yes you have to
plug the expression for beta hat into
the expression for alpha hat if you're
following along but it's all
straightforward algebra you end up
arriving at the equation y hat minus y
bar over the standard deviation of y
equals the correlation coefficient times
X minus X bar over the standard
deviation of X now unless you have
perfect linearity the correlation
coefficient is somewhere between
negative 1 and 1 so do those of you who
are new to this what does all that mean
well it means that the predicted value
of y given a regression on some variable
X is expected to be closer to the mean
of Y then X is to the mean of X now this
won't happen if you have perfect
linearity and R is equal to negative 1
or 1 but in the real world that never
happens and in fact the closer R is to 0
the more regression to the mean occurs
and now that hopefully I've convinced
you that regression to the mean is a
very real thing let's turn back to
Wikipedia for some examples of it and
there are examples of it in literally
every domain that you could think of
back to the example of people taking
tests so let's suppose you have people
taking two versions of a test on two
successive days what you're probably
going to see is that most of the people
who did the worst on day one do better
on day two and the people who did the
best on day one
do worse on day two and think of this in
terms of the first explanation I gave
where a score is based somewhat on
ability and somewhat unchaste a lot of
people who did really well at first did
so out of luck and so that's not
necessarily likely to play out the
second time around and similarly people
who did worse than their ability the
first time around will tend to see their
scores increase the second time that is
to be closer to the mean the second time
around for the same general reason and
there's plenty of other examples so
let's say we have a sports team and they
win a championship now obviously they
aren't guaranteed to win the second time
around and in fact the more of their
first success that was just due to luck
the less likely that they'll win again
next year although of course the flip
side of that is true - and the more of
the wind this year that can be
attributed to skill the better their
chances are next year similarly in
clinical trials a drug that outperformed
other candidate drugs is less likely -
if we do a second trial than a business
that had a highly well performing
quarter is expected to do more average
the next quarter unless there was an
underlying reason for doing better the
first time but the last example here is
actually the most telling one in my
opinion
so baseball players with great batting
averages tend to get cover features on
magazines then they do less well over
the next period of time that their
performance gets tracked thus leading to
this theory that appearing on the cover
of magazines causes them to perform less
well when no that's generally not it at
all it's just regression to the mean and
that's really the biggest takeaway here
we all want to attribute improvements or
declines due to something causing that
improvement or decline when in reality
we would expect to see some of these
things naturally just because of
regression to the mean this is something
any applied statistician or data
scientist needs to keep in mind because
if you're unaware of this you're likely
to make some serious interpretation
errors
and fall back into your own preconceived
notions and you should always ask
yourself this question can we rule out
that whatever we're observing is just
due to the regression effect if not you
may want to think about collecting more
data before you make too strong of a
conclusion so thanks for watching this
video if you enjoyed it and you would
like to support my work the most helpful
thing that you could do for me would be
to share this video otherwise at least
consider smashing the like button and
then leave a comment down below and let
me know when you've run to regression to
the mean then I'll see you all in the
not so distant future until then Richard
on data